le festival de cannes c'est un film qui
ne laissera personne indifférent
parait-il qui est présenté ce soir au
festival
voici quelques uns des qualificatifs que
j'ai relevé dans une seule dépêche
à propos du film la grande bouffe de
marco ferreri présentée par la france
ubuesque rabelaisien nihiliste cateau
logique pornographiques trivial
insoutenable cruel ça devrait être un
gros succès commercial mais on parle
aussi de grands morceaux de cinéma
oeuvre d'un moraliste qui s'élèvent
contre la société de consommation
on s'attend à beaucoup de réactions au
cours de la première ce soir ce
truculent obsède même un monument de
mauvais goût volontaires dont les
vedettes sont marcello mastroianni la
direction de marco ferreri philippe
noiret qui mériteraient à prix
d'interprétation michel piccoli andréa
ferréol et ugo tognazzi ugo tognazzi
réussi en particulier au cours d'un
banquet mémorable une extraordinaire
imitation de marlon brando dans le
parrain comme la maman et la [ __ ]
autres films de la sélection française
c'est une oeuvre qui ne peut que
profondément divisé les spectateurs dans
tous les cas qui ne laisse pas
indifférent
la mort sur la bouffe j'irai faire
o'shea
les parties histoire avec une petit
morceau de papier et avec lesquels on
parle la société de consommation
tam ont figé par les quatre personnages
qui sont dangereux société et n'hésite
pas à la société de consommation il ya
la vie sociale et logement sont
marrantes et l'associé consommation il
ya la société à l'effet est aussi le nom
elle tout ça l'idéal c'est ça pouvoir
continuer à manger comme ça des ultimes
essais magnifiques toiles à kayes
c'est un film désespérée quand même
puisque c'est un peu le non sens de la
vie après que la jeunesse soit parti
c'est pourquoi vous pensez qu'il ya on
peut faire un film
les squales les mauves et j'y connais
pas autre façon de vivre
et ça c'est encore plus désespérée voilà
faut pas fumer sans le des roches au
bois et tous les autres choses vous
savez faire la cuisine
non non non non non non non c'est pas si
vous êtes d'où vous venez vous plaidez
vous j'ai l'impression que c'est tout de
même un film sur l'absurdité de nos
habitudes quotidiennes et des nécessités
quotidiennes aussi d'ailleurs pas plus
que sur les slops visiter c'est trop
film
pas sûr le sentiment qu on filme
physiologie j'ai voulu comptes
industriels et quatre machines
physiologique jeux machines qui avant
d'avoir des sentiments il ya aussi des
nécessités et consuls hier en somme
c'est une farce monstrueuse que vous
avez voulu faire c'est pas on doit
toujours dit que les mots sont
difficiles et compliquées
ce n'est pas ce qu'est ce que vous
entendez pour bons souhaits je vivais
aux farces physiologique